notre page culture à présent avec
quelques questions sur l'art comment
at-il été perçu à travers les âges
quelle importance la corde ton
aujourd'hui et les réponses du
philosophe luc ferry de l'écrivain
philippe sollers qui viennent justement
de publier ce livre le sens du beau
george v go parce qu'elle criait
un livre d'art qui s'ouvre sur les
colonnes de buren peut apparaître comme
une invitation à la polémique mais le
propos dépassent largement cette notion
comment l'art est il perçu à travers les
siècles et aujourd'hui au moins une
oeuvre d'art c'est quand même la
rencontre d'une vérité quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre de la vérité et puis
d'une expression sensible de cette
vérité qui touche qui fait une émotion
qui fait peut-être qui provoque même un
grand plaisir esthétique et là j'ai
l'impression que on ne trouve au fond
aucun de ces deux éléments
j'ai l'impression qu'on est passé plutôt
dans l'ordre de la décoration de l'art
décoratif mais pour moi c'est pas tout à
fait de l'art
c'est l'artiste au fond du lit team ans
aujourd'hui plus que l'art parce que de
l'art vous en fais comme ça plus et
c'est plus ou moins bon lors confrontons
mais tout ça dans le même sac que ça
s'appelle l'art moderne alors il ya des
gens qui disent aussi formidable
d'autres il ajouté tech c'est ça mais il
faut aller voir au fond pour moi en tout
cas comme ans l'artiste vit avec 7,1 au
moyen âge par exemple comment l'artiste
vivait-il son art le musée de cluny en
offre les témoignages en toutes les
civilisations religieuse le nom de
l'artiste n'a pratiquement aucune
importance il n'est pas très important
ce nom de l'artiste parce que l'artiste
il est considérée non pas comme un
créateur comme quelqu'un qui invente
quelque chose de nouveau mais il est
considéré essentiellement comme un
intermédiaire entre le monde des dieux
ou le monde de dieu et le monde des
hommes il est un intercesseur plutôt
qu'un créateur l'arn devient lake qu'à
partir du xviie siècle
il s'écarte des thèmes religieux pour
reproduire la vie quotidienne
on a si vous voulez une humanisation de
l'art une humanisation des sujets de
l'ap cette laïcisation de la et quelque
chose qui est peut être le point de
départ véritablement de l'art moderne
ainsi au fil du temps l'artiste
attachera plus d'importance à son
langage à sa signature qu'à la réalité
reproduites
c'est une des conclusions du sens
dubroeucq luc ferry publie avec
l'amicale complicité de philippe sollers
un ouvrage